では よろしくお願いします
アッパマーデ
ラトー ビク クーパマーデ バヘダッシーヴァー サンニョージェナン アヌン トゥーラン ダハン アッギーワ ガッチャティ
アッパマーデ ラトー ビク クーパマーデ バヘダッシーヴァー サンニョージェナン アヌン トゥーラン ダハン アッギーワ
ガッチャティ という三十一番目
説明してから進みます
アッパマーデ ラトー ビク
これ注釈そうはないんですけど
アッパマーデという章ですから
アッパマーデについてずっと語っていることで
そのアッパマーデということは好んでいるビク
ラトーっていうのは何かにやり続けるという
何かすごく好んで釘 釘付けてやるという意味で
ラトー ラティという言葉を使うんです
それでこのアッパマーデに釘付いているということで
アッパマーデ ラトー そのビクは
それからパマーデ バヘダッシーヴァー
アッパマーデを好んでやっているんだから
パマーデについてはバヘダッシーヴァー
危険性を見るんですね
いわゆる良くないものだと
悪いものだと ちょっと危険だと感じる
そのビクがサンニョージェナン アヌン トゥーラン
サンニョージェナンというのは煩悩のこと
アヌンというのはすごい微妙な細かい煩悩
トゥーランというのは派手に心に現れる煩悩
そのどちらでもダハン
燃やしてしまうということで
アッギーワ 火のように
火は小さなものも大きなものを燃え燃やしてしまうんですね
そのように燃えてしまう
アッギーワ ガッチャティということは最後の動詞で
火のごとく燃やしていくのであるというふうに
で この まず大体の意味を考えてから詳しい説明いたしますので
ずいぶん簡単な単純なことを言ってるんです
山火事を考えれば 山火事が起きると
小さな草とかね 藪とか葉っぱとか
それも燃やし燃やしながら
大きな木まで何だかんだで燃やしてしまうんです
で 山火事がもう何も残らず燃やしてしまうような感じで
アッパマーダということを実践すれば
心の汚れというものが
煩悩というものが全部消えてしまうと
燃えてしまうということです
で それからの説明なんですけど
ではアッパマーダって何なのかと
ずっと説明してきたんです
この章は全部たった一言葉アッパマーダという一つの言葉の意味
説明する章でしたからね
だから繰り返して今日説明する気にはなりませんだけど
同じことを繰り返さなくてはいけないんです
アッパマーダは一般的には不放逸というふうな日本語がございまして
怠らないこと そう言うと
なんかまあ怠けないっていうふうな意味にはなります
しかし それよりもすごい微妙な難しい意味
があるんです これは専門用語だから
ただ辞書を引いて そうですか
不放逸ですか 怠けないことかって
それだけでは意味が通るわけじゃありません
専門用語にはそれらしき別な意味があるんです
科学の場合でも ごく一般的な英語を使ってますけど
一般的な英語がわかるんだからといって科学わかるわけじゃないんです
それぞれの科学分野で
自分は別な意味で その専門用語として言葉を使ってますから
それでアッパマーダというのは
仏教の全体的にある一番大事なキーワード
これより大事な言葉がないんです
この一言葉に仏道全部入るんです
仏道というのは方法ですからね
ブッダの道なんですね
お釈迦様おっしゃっている真理というものはまたたくさんありますけど
方法論といえば 仏道といえば
このたった一言葉に入るんです
だから我々はアッパマーダという不放逸ということを実践するならば
もう完全に仏道というものは全部実践しているものになるんです
だからお釈迦様が亡くなるほんのちょっと前でも
その一言葉を最後に言い残して涅槃に入るんです
アッパマデーナサンパーデータという一言葉で
で それその言葉を言い残すんですね
お釈迦様の最後の言葉っていうのはもうすごい言葉で
全てまとめて言ってるんです
今まで教えた全ての真理を一行にまとめる
ワヤダンマサンカーラ
サンカーラというものは
組み立てたもの 出来上がったものっていうのは全てなくなるものであると
全て消えるものであると
いわゆる無常ですね 一切は無常であるという
我々知っている世界っていうのは全て出来上がった世界
我々の心も出来上がったものであって
独立して存在するものではないんです
例えば 何か見ていると
何かあると見ているんであって
視覚が生まれるんであって
視覚という心が生まれるので
何も見るものない場合は視覚が生まれるわけじゃないんです
聴覚っていうのは心なんです
聞いているんだぞと 聞くためには音がないと聞くという心が生まれてこないんです
そうやって我々の心も出来上がったものなんです
何もない時は何か考えているんですね
過去の出来事やいろいろなこと
その時も心っていうのはいつでも出来上がっちゃうんです
何か何か組み合わせて
だから心さえも出来上がったもので
体も出来上がったもので
世界も出来上がったもので
それは仏教ではサンカーラという言葉で言ってるんです
出来上がったものという意味なんです
サンカーラは で 日本語はないんですね
サンカーラに対する正しい日本語の言葉っていうのは
だから私は現象という言葉を使ってはいるんです
全て現象であると  その出来上がったものは
まあ消えるに決まってるんです
私たちに聴覚があるといっても
それは音がある時だけなんです
音がなくなったら聴覚はもう消えちゃうんです
視覚があるといっても
永遠に視覚があるわけじゃないんです
見るものがなくなったら
もう何もないんです 見えないんです
だからこの消えるには決まっている
それがお釈迦様の真理を全部まとめたらそれだけなんです
だからお釈迦様はそれで全てのサンカーラは
あらゆる現象はなくなる
なくなるんだよと 消えていくんだよと
それは教えで それから修行法
故に不放逸で頑張りなさいと
アッパマーデナサンパーデタというのは
不放逸を行いなさいというぐらいの意味なんです
不放逸で頑張りなさいと言ったら
ちょっと意味がまた崩れちゃいます
不放逸を行いなさい サンパーデタというのは何かをするという意味ですから
だから無常と不放逸という二言葉に仏教全てなんです
そういうのを覚えてほしいんです
だから仏教は難しくてわからないなのことだと思っているでしょうね
まあそれは無理がないんですから
あまりにも大量にあるんだから
そんな人間の寿命は足らなくなっちゃいます
全部勉強しようとしたっても
しかし それはそんなに心配する必要はないし
ただものすごく見事にまとめているんです
それで無常という言葉にブッダの真理すべてまとめているんです
無常というたったこの二言葉に
アニッチャというパーリ語では一つの言葉なんです
で それで実践方法 我々はどうするべきかという我々の道をアッパマーデ不放逸という一言葉にしているんです
で 初めて聞く方々にアッパマーデの意味をこれから説明します
この言葉は分解してみると
アッパマーデというのはマダという言葉が入ってあって
マッドという英米でという言葉入ったり
マッドというのは酔ってしまうという興奮状態
混乱状態を示す動詞なんです
それにPAかPRというものが入っちゃうと
もうそれにも入り込んでいるということで
だから酔っている状態で
で それはパマーデなんですね
酔っている興奮状態っていうのは何なのかというと
ものははっきり見てない状態
混乱状態だから 興奮状態だから
何もわかってない状態にいるんです
それの反対 いわゆる常に明晰に心を保つ状態はアッパマーデなんです
だから酔った状態でいてはいけないということなんです
で それだけで仏教の全部言ったことに
それでもならないんです
で 酔ってあんた興奮状態で酔っているんでは
あんた混乱しているんではないかと言ったって
人はあんまりそれを認めないんです
酔っ払いの人でも そんなことないんだぞと
しっかりしてるんだぞと言うんだからね
人間というのはいくら混乱していたっても認めないんです
だから混乱している人を認めないんだから
普通の人は認めるわけでもないんですね
自分が興奮状態で生きているんだと
混乱状態で生きているんだということをね
いわゆるわけもわからない状態で生きている
みんな だから我々は自分の人生を観察しなくちゃいけない
我々は本当に物事はちゃんと知って
理解して生きているんでしょうかと
今までも生きてきたんだから
どうやって生きてきたんですかね
きちんと自分の判断能力があって
自分でしっかりとこれはする
これはしない こういうわけで
これをする こういうわけで
これはやめるという明晰な状態で
いつでも心がもうフル回転して機能している状態で
しっかりと生きたことがありますかと
それは一度もないんですよ
ただ生きているだけ はっきり言えば
何かをして生きているだけ
それ何かを何でするのかといったってもはっきりわからないんです
その場でその場で親に言われたんだからとか
課長に言われたんだから
上司に言われたんだからとか
そういう何とか何とかで
なんかもう誰かに尻を叩かれているような生き方なんです
自分で判断して これはする
これはしないという生き方はしていないんです
そうできるわけでもないんです
自分でこれをする これはしないということにするためには
相当な理解能力 相当な知恵が必要なんです
そんなのはないんだからね
生まれるとか何もわからないでしょうに
だから生まれた人はもう興奮状態で
混沌混乱状態で生きているんですよ
それでしたら大人になってきたらしっかりするかというと
全然ない 死ぬまで同じパターンで生きていくんです
だから 人間の生き方は放逸的な
パマーダ的な生き方なんです
誰も自分の足で歩んでいるわけじゃないんです
人生は 抑え 抑えられて押されて
ただなんとか生きているだけ
いろんな条件 押しちゃうとしょうがないでしょうにね
たくさん人が集まって
どこかある一定の方向へ歩いているんだったら
こちら逆に歩いたって歩けないんだから
だから あらゆる条件に私たちは押されて
ただ前々と進んでいくだけ
進むと言ったこれは言葉だけ
進むではなくて 年取るだけ
時間の進み方だけなの
別になにか進んでいるわけじゃないんです
我々の生き方っていうのは
こうやっていろんな条件に
条件に押されてしまって
ただ時間を経過していて
それでやがて死ぬ この大衆に押されて前々へ進んで進んで
それからどこかで踏みつけられるというような生き方なんです
それが違いますかと その生き方は
仏教は全ての人間の生き方はそういう生き方であると
押して押されて前に進む人は
自分の意思で自分で判断して
この方向に行くぞということでやっているわけじゃないんです
我々は今までやっている全てのことも
そうやってあらゆる条件に押されているだけ
条件 2種類あります 一つは社会
外 で 誰も子供でしたからね
初めは それで親 押すんです
それから先生たち押すんです
それ先輩やら それからずっと人生を他人が押してるんです
必ずしも先輩というわけじゃないんですよ
結婚したら子供に押されるんだからね
自分が子供を指導してるつもりなんですけど
よくよく見ると子供に操られてるんです
だから 例えば会社の社長ならね
命令する権利があって
会社を支配して管理して会社を押していると思ってるでしょうね
違うんですよ 会社というシステムを作っちゃ
そのシステムに押されてるんです
自由がなくなっちゃうんです
だから我々を推してる条件っていうのは
そうやって外にあるんですね
それは一つ 自由がなくなっちゃうんです
自分の体も仏教から見ると外だと思った方がいいんです
体にも押されてるんです
肉体もいろんなことを言ってるんですよ
我々はもう言う通りにやる
自分の意思で もう何とか自由な意思で何とかしようかなと思ったらできないんですよ
もう体何か条件を出すとそれに応じないと
だから体もいろんな条件を出してくれる
24時間出してるんですよ
だから肉体の条件も外の環境だと思った方がやりやすい
理解しやすい 子供に押されてるだけではなくて
自分の人生は自分の体にも押されてるんです
例えば何か誰かと約束して外に行って遊びましょうと
したんですけど 前の夜
自分が何か体の調子が悪くなっちゃって
お腹を壊しちゃって 倒れちゃうと出てきますかね
体が条件出しているんです
そうすると体の言うことを聞いて別なことをやめるしかないんです
そういうふうに体も条件あれこれと出す
それも外 次に我々は内から押されているんです
中から 体も外だったら中って何なのかね
それが自分たちの感情なんです
で 押されて生きてるといろいろ感情が出てくるんですよ
気持ちいいとかね 楽しいとか悔しいとか嫌とかね
嫉妬 憎しみやら 怒りとかいろんな感情が心に生まれるんですよ
それから感情も自分を押すんです
だから人間という生命には 1片も自由がないんです
あのキリスト教とイスラム教はね
神様が人間に自由を与えているんだと言ってる
何言ってるんでしょうか
私はさっぱりわからない
どこに自由があるのかと
ああいうのは ただ単にこのただのおばさん連中の話みたいな感じで
もうもう もう昔の連中
人々はね もう何か何か考えて世間話するような無駄話
こうではないか ああではないか
これはこうじゃないかとかね
それ程度の話なんですよ
だから世界を見ると偉大なる神様
自分が信仰しているのに
唯一の絶対的な神様 神様が作った人間が信じてないんですね
なんで自分たちだけっていうことになってくると
それに出てくる感情なんですね
やっぱり神様が絶対的で
全知全能だから この人々にはもしかすると自由を与えているんではないか
だったら自分たちも自由になればいいのに
神を信じないで で その人々に迷惑をかける
神が自由を与えたならば
神に権利がないんですよ
汝 私を信じなさいということを言う権利はないんです
憲法違反です でも堂々と言ってるんですよね
汝 我のみを信じ 信じるべきであると
イスラム教にははっきり書いてある
他の神々は絶対信じべからずと
ただでは済みます それから脅し文句があるんです
そんな権利あるはずがないでしょう
神には もし自由を与えたならば
だからもうちょっと頭がほんのちょっとでも分かったら
この聖書の書き方は変えるんですよ
私がみんな作ったんだと
だから私は誰にも自由を与えてないんだと
だから私を奴隷にしなさいと言うべきなのに
そうすると論理は成り立ってますけどね
自由に何が何かできるかと調べてみなさいよと
そういうためにはかなり知恵が必要なんです
その知恵ひと欠けらもない世界だから
そこまでは行ってないんで
だからこの自由ということはよくみんな使ってますけど
あんなのはあまりにも俗的な
あのニュースでいえばワイドショーみたいな
まあガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ何もいろんなこと言うんだけど
何も情報ない  行のスクリプトを勝手に書いて
では警視庁からどうでしょうかと
では現場から それから誰か誰かも
だからあんたはみんな同じスクリプト読み上げる
同じ文章を回ぐらい もう分以内で聞かなくちゃいけない
回ぐらい あんな感じなんですね
世の中っていうのは だからこの真剣に考えると
人間にどこに自由あるのかと
我々は押されているだけ
押されて時間を取っているだけ
何かをして 何に押されているかというと
まず外から押されている
外といえば体まで入っていて
そこで奴隷みたいに生きてるんだから
どのように生きるかとみんなもうすぐわかるんですよ
大体まあ時になると 日本だったらもうほとんどの人がご飯を食べているでしょうね
もうほとんど決まってます
時 時ぐらいになってくるとみんな寝ている
だからどこに自由あるんでしょうかと
では寝ていない人もいるんではないか
寝てるんだから寝てないだけ
あるいはもう深夜バイトやってるとかね
自分に時間は深夜しかないんだから
バイトに行ってるんだから寝るわけにはいきませんし
それだけの話で自由がないんです
その人 寝る自由は だから起きてるだけのこと
他の人にはもう仕事終わって家に帰ってお風呂に入ってご飯も食べて
12時 12時半になりましたと
そうすると寝ないで朝までいる自由がないんです
寝るんです だから外から押されてあって
それから内からも押さえられてあって
内っていうのは まあまあまとめて言えばあらゆる感情ですね
これはたくさんあります
好き嫌いも感情でしょうし
怒り憎しみも感情でしょうし
で それによっても我々は押さえられて何かをする
悔しいという感情が入ってくると何かをする
憎しみの感情が入ると何かをする
することも決まっている
だから瞬間でも自由がないんです
その生き方がパマーダという生き方なんです
何も発展ない生き方 何の成長もない生き方
ただ押されて時間的に前へもう進んでいるだけ
だから人間というのはもうただ生まれて大きくなって年取って死ぬ
それはどんな嘘を誤魔化して言ったっても
それしか誰も何もやってないんです
では 私は何々をやったんではないかと威張っちゃう
威張りたいでしょうね
でもあれは条件に押されてやってるだけ
本当にあなた そういうことを自分で判断して
自分で決めてやったものでしょうか？と言えば
全くそうじゃないんです
例えば難しい研究したり
勉強したりする人々は
その人々が頑張っているのではないかと
違うんです 研究もできない
勉強もできない もう人々はすごい頑張ってるな
それは自分が嫌だからやってないだけのことで
やる人々はそれにもうもうくぎ付けになっているだけ
やめてくださいと やめられません
そういう人々には やめてどうするのかと
考古学と言ったりして穴を掘ったりいろんなことやってるでしょうね
やめてください くだらんことやめられませんね
あれ 科学だといっても
まあ信じられないくだらんバカなことやっていて
じゃあやめてくださいと言ってもやめられないんです
だからまあまあ そういう一般人から見れば難しいことをやってるんだと見えても
その人々にとってはそんなもうどうったことない
それはもうやめられなくなってるだけ
ですから そのひとかけらも自由がない
生かされている状況では
人間には成長はゼロ 向上はゼロ
見込みはない 全ての生命の先はもう真っ暗
それが普遍的な真理として理解してほしいんです
難しいと思いますけど
生命の生き方というのはそういう生き方であると
だから 自分自身の人生だけ見ればいいんです
それでこの真理わかるんです
例えば皆様方 自分で服の色とか選ぶでしょ
自由でしょうね よく見てください
本当に自由で選ぶのかと
選ばせてるだけではないんですかね
あらゆる条件から では
その髪型は自分で決めたんですかね
そのどこかに何かそういう商売やってる店に行って
私にはこういうスタイルの髪を
こういうスタイルの髪を切ってくれと
なんか自分で選んでるような気分でしょ？違うんですよ
何かの真似なんです 誰かにやらやらされてるだけなんです
だからこの まあこういう自由っていうものは存在しないんです
このやらされているということは条件ですから
髪型選ぶ時でも 髪の色を選ぶ時でも
もう周りの環境を見て自分が判断する
だから何に判断するかとももう決まってます
別な判断できません  わかりやすい例で言えば
お腹が空いたらご飯食べる
何か食べることに決まってあるんであって
お腹が空いたんだから泳ぎましょうという答えは出てこないんです
お腹が空いたんだからサイクリングしましょうとかね
は出てこないんです お腹が空いたらサイクリングしましょうと思ったら笑うでしょ？バカじゃないかと
お腹が空いたらご飯食べることはしっかりした理性的な生き方ではないかと思うでしょう
だから我々は理性的に生きてるつもりなんです
結局は決まってるパターンで生きてるだけ
そちらの理性でも何もないんです
この因果法則というブッダの話はそちらから現れてくるんです
因果法則を説いたところで
人間には自由がないということなんです
でも 因果法則を発見したところでありがたいことが条件に抑えられるんだから
条件を変えると抑える方法も変ります
変えます 変わります ほんのわずかなそれだけしか
何かあの藁ですね 流されて溺れてる人には
それしかないんです それにもすがるのは
やっぱり生きることはもう嫌
こんな不自由な生き方はっていうのを思う人だけなんです
激しく流され だから藁で浮き輪であったっても
つかむ余裕もないんです
もう お釈迦様は浮き輪出してますよ
取れないんですよ もうものすごい渦巻きに
ものすごい激しい激流に流されているのは
もうそんな余裕がないんです
流されて溺れて死ぬということしかない状態
しかし 流されていて溺れるんだぞ
これが良くない もう嫌だと思った人が周りちょっと見るんです
浮輪でも何でも何かないんでしょうか
枝でも何かつかまるものは
そこで流れは変えられますけどね
で それはブッダ お釈迦様おっしゃっている解脱の道になるんです
それがアッパマーダという一言葉でまとめているんです
それで人間が不自由で完全自由というのはひとかけらもなく
完全に束縛されてあって
生かされているだけ それをこの悪循環を解凍する解毒と何て言いますか
解錠するためには たった一つしか方法ないんです
それが流されていたっていいんですけど
その状況に気づく その状況に気づく
だからその状況って瞬間瞬間流されているんだから
その瞬間瞬間 自分が今どういうことかと
自分に気づいてみる それが観察するということになるんですね
だから 例えばすごくお腹が空いている
で そちらに食べるものもある
お腹が空いているんだから食べたいという気持ちもある
その気持ちに動かされて
自分が食べ物を取って食べるんだと
で 気づいてみるんです
その気づく機能があると
ちょっと違うんです かなり違うんです
籠の中にいる鳥が 自分がずっと自分の世界は籠やと思ってえらい気分よくいるよりは
自分が掴まれていると
籠の中に 知っている鳥とは違うんですよ
自分が籠で生まれて籠で籠の外の世界は何もないんだと思っている鳥は大馬鹿者なんです
でも籠に自分を掴まれてるんだと
知ってる鳥は状況を知っているんです
その鳥だけ もし籠のあれ
閉めてるドアみたいなものをね
もうもう閉め忘れた瞬間に逃げることはできるんです
自分はもう籠に住むものだと思っている人は
もうあれを開けといたっても逃げていかない
外へ出しても またもう不安でまた籠の中に入るんです
それでこの この瞬間瞬間気づく
瞬間瞬間を観察する そういうことによって
どんどん人間の心が成長していくんです
だから自由を味わいたければ
この気づく 気づく瞬間で自由なんです
やられているわけじゃないんです
その場合は 自分の判断で生きているはずなんです
お腹が空いたんだから
ただ反射だけで食べる人は奴隷なんです
お腹が空いたことを観察して
何食べるかと判断して
それでちゃんと観察しながら食べる人がそこは自由が成り立ってるんです
そこでこの外からの影響
で それがもう体ある限りのことだから
周りから自分を奴隷にしているのは
もう自分が生きているだけだけの話でしょうし
お腹が空くのも体ある時だけの話でしょうし
だからそんな大きな問題ではありません
しかし 気づかない人にとってはものすごい大きな問題なんです 「
あんた癌ですよ」と言ったら
医者はもしかすると４年は持ちますよと思っているかもしれません
だけど 聞いただけでびっくりしちゃって
もう半年で死んじゃうんです
それがもう気づくことはできない人にはそうなっちゃうんです
気づくことをしているのは癌ですよ
これはもう治らないんだ
もう体ある時だけの話ですからということで落ち着くんです
そんな苦しいんですけど
それは生きる時だけでしょうと
それで親しい人々が親しい人いたって生きてる間だけの話ですからね
死んじゃったら何もないんだから
親しくも何もない その連中は忘れちゃいますからね
だからこのまあ ここまでの話だよということはわかるんですよ
しかし 一番ややこしいのは内から押されるところなんですね
それが体と関係ないんです
関係あるんですけど やっぱり
かなり別な働きなんですね
怒りとか憎しみとか欲とか嫉妬とかね
落ち込みとか高慢とか
たくさん煩悩がありますよ
それが中から出てくる感情なんです
例えば怒るために体の何か体格とか何か必要ですか？どれぐらい量を食べる人間かというと
人間食べる量は人間個人個人で
体質で決めるんです 体の大きさで
それからなんとかという
あれ 何て言いますか この
消化するシステムもいろいろ人によって違いますからね
ですから 同じ体であろうとも
二人だったら食べる量が変わるんです
では怒りもそうですかね
例えば体が大きい人は怒らないとか
体が細い人は怒るとか
こういう体格の人は嫉妬する
こういう体格の人は嫉妬しないとかありますかね
目がこういうふうに視力はこういうこれぐらいある人は欲がたくさんなりますと
視力はこれぐらいある人には欲がないとか
それはないでしょう だから体と
関係ないんです 太った人も怒るし
痩せた人も怒るんです
犯罪を起こす起こすのはすごい筋肉モリモリの体格ある人というわけじゃないんです
ものすごい弱々しい人間でも犯罪を起こすんです
怒りで 子供でも平気で一人
二人 三人ぐらい殺すでしょうに
子供よりはかなり体力ある大人もしてないでしょうに
ものすごい人を殺したヒトラーというのはね
ドイツ人として見ると随分体が小さいでしょうね
ドイツ人は結構体格のある背が高い人間ですけど
それでみんな支配して独裁者でも殺すは殺すは殺すは嘘を言っては殺すはいろいろごまかししては殺すは
あの強烈な怒り 憎しみ
もしすごい体格の人であっても
なかなか体力あってももう戦うことにもう興味あるとか
そういう話じゃないんです
あまりにも弱々しくて腰抜けなんですけど
でも感情はすごいもので
そういうことですから
我々の内から抑えられている感情っていうのは体とは関係ない
ということは もうガンなんか死ぬまでのことでしょうとか言って放っておくことはできなくなるんです
子供は親をいじめると
ああ まあこいつはもう一人前になって独立するまででしょうというふうに我慢するでしょうに
独立したらもうもうそれでも関係ないと
いくらか落ち着けるでしょうというふうなことはできません
感情の場合は なぜならば
体とは関係ないんです
嫌な人がいると怒るとするでしょ
この嫌な人がいるんだから怒ってるんであって
この人は出て行ったら怒りませんよとかないんで
帰ったって怒っているんです
それで人が相手のことを心配して言ったことなのに
聞いたバカがそれにすごいカンカン怒ってるってこといくらでもあるでしょうに
ただ言葉でしょうに それも相手が心配して言ったことでしょうに
なんでそれについてすっごく怒って
不自然な行動までするのかと
だからこれが内なる原因なんですね
これが体が潰れても体と関係ないということは
因果法則から見ると体が潰れてもやばいということなんです
体が潰れると同時に感情も潰れてしまうならば
本当にもう体と一体で問題はないんです
だからよく客観的に見ると
我々の感情というのは体とはそれほど関係なく
大体逆方向になるんですよ
例えば 本当に体力ある人はあんまり戦いたいとかね
喧嘩したいという気分がないんです
弱いんだったら 頭の中でも戦いたくて戦いと喧嘩したくて
その妄想ばっかりでしょうに
すごい強い人を相手見たら
もうやっぱりもう殴らない方がいいやと
もうもう弱いでしょうと
だからなんかこの感情というのは体の機能と反対方向へ働いてますよ
まあそれを反対に働いて
例えばすごく美しい人は他人のことは嫉妬しないでしょ
よく嫉妬する人を見てみると
もうすぐ分かります 何も自慢できることは持ってないんです
惨めなんです それで その反対方向へ感情が働くんです
だからものすごい欲張りやっていうのは
この大富豪かじゃないんですよ
貧乏な人なんです で ホームレスの人々はちょっとした場所にも喧嘩するんです
自分の場所ではないのに
これはすごい怖いことなんですよ
だから仏教の業論で で
与える人は豊かになるんだと
欲張りが貧乏になるんだとか話ありますね
こういう話なんです 反対方向に働くんですから
与える人には欲がないんです
欲がないということは
物質的に見るとすごい豊かということなんです
だから与える人は与えることは内なる感情だから
生まれ変わってもすごい豊かに生まれるんです
嫉妬する人はすごい醜く生まれるんだと
だから嫉妬と醜さ 物質的には醜い
うちの原因は嫉妬 つなげています
それでこの仏教でいう戒律なんか守る人は
来世ですごい人気者になるんだよと
みんなその人のことを信頼するんだよと
生まれ変わったら何のことなく信頼する
我々の世界を見ても もういろんな人を我々信じているんです
大勢の人々が 政治家なんか信頼してるんです
顔を見たことないでしょうに
何者か 性格は何なのかさっぱりわからないんですけど
あの人なら投票するんだそうと
なんででしょうかね それはもう過去生で
まあ戒を守ったんだから
そういう結果になるんだよと
それはどういうことかというと
戒律を守るということは約束を守るということなんです
それで信頼できるということなんです
だから生まれ変わったら
もう自分で何もやってないのに
みんな自分を信頼するようになっちゃうんです
だから この業論の世界ではいろいろそうやって
あの食いも細かい あの説明いろいろあるんですけど
聞いたら本当かなとみんな疑うかもしれませんだけど
厳密に考えると もうそんなに難しいことでもないんです
もうただ ごく普通な因果法則をお釈迦様教えられているだけ
[背景音楽]だから我々は物質的に恵まれているということが使えるかどうかは
置かれている状況と反対の方向に感情がいくんです
そこで仏教で煩悩というのはこの感情なんですよ
汚れなんです これ一番やばい
危ない 体と関係ない ないよ
体と関係それほどなく
もう勝手に機能する だから
醜い人は嫉妬してしまうのは当たり前
決まってますけど だからといって美しい人は嫉妬しないという約束もないんですよ
豊かな豪奢な富豪家の人があまり欲張らないということはごく当たり前の話ですけど
だからといって金持ちはケチで欲張っていないという話でもないんです
だから あまりもう現実と関係なく心が動いちゃうんですね
金持ちなのにとんでもないケチもいるでしょうに
すごく美しいなのに 人のことを嫉妬する人はいるでしょうね
例えば 自分には素晴らしい歌唱力があるのに
他の歌手のことはいじめたり
邪魔させたり からくりやったりするでしょうし
だから心の汚れっていうのは結構もうタチが悪いんです
信頼できないんです で
これ例えば何でも自分の希望通りにあると怒らないっていうのは普通でしょうに
例えば子供のケース見ると
親がちゃんと言う通りにやってくれるわ
もう学校でも仲良く楽しく生きていられるわと
それだったら怒らないくてニコニコと笑っているのは当たり前なんですけど
でも怒るでしょう 例えば母親がもう子供にちゃんと美味しい弁当作ってあげる
そうすると怒らないはずない
それにも怒る場合あります
もういらん 要りませんよとかね
わしはもう買って食べますからお金くれとか
で 例えば奥さんが家の仕事はきちんとやって
家族を大事に守って その上すごい美人で
子供たちもきちんと面倒を見て
旦那に一つ文句言わないでいると
旦那が奥さんのことは完璧に喜んでいるのは普通でしょうに
不倫するはずないでしょうね
それでもうちはつまらないんだからって言って不倫するんです
奥さんは美人でもないし
もう全然もう何て言いますか
未練もなくなっちゃって
まあ不倫するならばそこら辺のいくらか常識的な理屈は成り立ちますけど
だから感情っていうのはなかなかこの条件に沿って動くんじゃなくて
結構勝手に動くんです
だから体が壊れても壊れたら終わりだ
大丈夫だということはできません
あのあの教頭で もう日本中あの鳥インフルエンザ広げた人がこれで自分と奥さんが死んじゃったんだから
じゃあ万々歳 終わったと
勘違いです 自分のあの恐ろしい感情がもうついていくんです
だから儲かることしか頭になかったでしょ
自分が儲ければいい 人はどうでもいいという
そういう儲ければいいというか
欲でしょう 欲によって全てなくなるっていうのはお釈迦様の教えなんです
命までなくなっちゃったんです
法律だったら人殺したら命なくなります
あの人は法律で裁けても
裁いてもまだまだ日本でそういう法律もそんなにできてないんだから
あの法律っていうのは事件が起きたら作るものでしょうに
彼が報告しなかったということで
まあいくらか損害賠償になっちゃうと高いお金を払う羽目になりますけど
罰金としては大した罰金ついてないんですよ
でもその人はもう自分で処刑決めたんです
命まで 金儲かろうと思ったところで命までなくなるという
これはもう因果法則で
体のことだったら自殺すればそれで万々歳ですけど
感情は残念ながら体と関係なく回転するんです
それがもう輪廻のすごい恐ろしさなんです
それでお釈迦様が推薦するのはこの観察しなしましょうと
瞬間瞬間の感じを見てみなさいと
嫉妬が生まれたらこれが嫉妬だと
見ると嫉妬に操られることがなくなるんです
これが怒りやと思ったら
怒りでガチャガチャガチャガチャ何か変なことをして悪い結果になる
そこでストップするんです
かなり管理される 例えばむっちゃ怒ったら人を殴ったり
物を壊したりするのは自然法則なんです
でも自分がものすごい簡単怒ってるんだよとわかった人は
決まってることはしないんですよ
次に決まってるんです
相手を殴るということは
これはやらなくなっちゃうんです
その瞬間自由なんです
感情に騙されてないんです
それで結構自己管理できます
自己管理できたっていうことは
仮にでもその人は自由なんです
完全自由というではないんだけど
それなりに自由なんです
それでそれなりに自由で生きてる人は
次の瞬間 次の瞬間 次の瞬間もそれなりに自由でいると
どんどん自由ということはどんどんどんどんどんどん上がっていくんです
そうすると我々の自由は奪っているのは体ではなくて感情でしょ？煩悩でしょ
煩悩が切れて切れて切れて切れていくんです
それで完全たる自由というものは得られるんです
完全たる自由を得られた人には煩悩は一切なし
でも体の欲はそれでもあります
まあ死ぬまでだということだからということで
そこを全然気にしない
例えば足の骨が折ってすごく歩けなくなる
まあつなげるまでのことだからね
それは気にする必要はないんだと
すごくニコニコでいられます
そういうことで そういう人の子供とかなんとか死んだっても
まあまあ子供っていうのは死ぬまでのことだから
じゃあそうするぐらいやりましょうっていうことで
すごく冷静にいるんです
憎しみはスーッと持ち運ぶことはないんです
日本の美徳ですけどね
憎しみと もう被害者は
酒鬼薔薇ケースの場合でも
テレビでもとにかくそんなもうこれほど残酷なことをして
その人を自由にさせて
それで被害者の気持ちはどうでしょうかと
被害者の気持ち 憎しみに応じることは何で必要でしょうかね
憎しみならばどこまででも憎しめるでしょうに
例えばその子供を殺す
それで親が納得いくんですかね？被害者の親が
じゃあもう子供の親も殺しましょうと
親戚も殺しましょうと
ということになるでしょうね
憎しみにはキリがないんだから
日本の美徳している道徳で世界では被害者の方がものすごい悪いんです
加害者よりも 加害者がもう何か条件に迫られて決まってる行動をしただけのはもう自由じゃないんだからね
それにしたら被害者はもうもうもう無制限に無料に怒り
憎しみを持ち運ぶ それで幸福になると思いますかね
過去で悪いことをしたんだから
今世ですっごい悲しい経験を得る
でも過去の同じ癖で相手を憎んで憎んで
将来ももっとひどいことになる
だから自分の子供が突然誰かに殺されるっていうことは
自分 子供の寿命だから
それはしょうがないんですよ
でも親はそれからものすごい悲しみ
別れの悲しみ 味わわなくちゃいけないでしょうね
それは自分の業なんです
それだったら人を慈しめばいいでしょうに
やっぱり愛する者に邪魔するっていうことはこんな大変なことだから
みんなお互いの関係あるでしょうに
動物でももう家族でしょうに
だから生命にはこんな悲しみはあってほしくないというふうに慈しみということを育てれば
もうその問題はそれで解放するんですよ
解決します でもその代わりにもう憎しみ
そうすると将来にまた同じ経験に合わなくちゃいかないんです
輪廻の中でも 一回で終わることはしないんです
それで私が言いたいのは
子供殺されて悲しんでいる親が
それはそちらの業で大変悲しんでいる
酒鬼薔薇という青年が自分がやった悪いことの償いをすればいいんです
だから私がやった悪いことの悪い結果が私が受けるのであって
それで誰かさんの気分を何とかするために私は苦しみを受けるということは理屈に合わないんです
だから法律で個人個人を裁くんです
被害者の立場を考えて裁きませんって言ったら
もう裁ききれなくなっちゃうんです
もし被害者がもうこんな子供育てる教育システムは駄目ですよと
日本の社会も駄目ですよと言っちゃうと
日本の社会まで裁くんですかね
だから憎しみにはキリがないんだから
だからあなたがやった悪いことをあなたが受けなさい
それでストップしなくちゃいけないんですよ
特にもうもうこのアメリカでもあるんですけど
このくだらん愚かどもの感情で判決出す
日本でもよくやる これでは公平な法律にはならなくなっちゃうんです
法律は人殺しにはどんな罰かと
その人には殺し意図があったかないかと
自己管理できたかないかと
それぐらいで判決すればいいんです
それであのサリンケースで一人の女性なんですけど
会社に行く行って時は
あの何とかところでね
サリン毒が体に入って
これで大変意識もなくなって
長い間苦しんでいて 今体も動かないんですよ
その時点からもう完全な障害者になっちゃって
もうろくに喋れない もう笑えない
もう人をわからない もう重度の障害なんです
やっともう年ぐらい前で
やっと家に帰ることができて
もうもう今も喋れないんです
頭もはっきり機能しない
だからもう重度の障害者にはなっているんです
それがもう誰から見ても本当にもういけないことで
悲しいことで あれほど元気でバリバリ仕事をしていた若い女の人が
もう今はもう何もできない
自分では歩くことも立つことも何もできない状態で
喋ることもできない状態
それでその女の人をその家族の憎しみに適する罰を与えられますかね
麻原にできません 麻原には麻原が犯した罪に罰を与える
それは理解してもらわないと
もう人間というのはどこまで腐って苦しみ作るかということも切りがないんです
そこであの徳光というもうアホが言ってもうインタビューするんですね
泣きながら悔しいですねとかね
もうもっと怒れと言っても
彼女もあんた何か言いたいけど死ねという
それもあまり発想もできないんです
だから あの女の人がサリンにやられて一生台無しになって
すごい元気な人で生まれて
今一生障害者で生活しなくちゃいけないのに
その上もうもうもうきりがない怒りで苦しんでいて
これっていいのかと それでその被害者の方に何かしてあげたことになるのかと
徳光さんが言ってもっと怒り
もっと憎しめということを言っても
だからこの感情っていうのは恐ろしいもので
自分のもので これが持っていくんですよ
体壊れても なぜそれだけ持っていくのかというと
やっぱり世の中の因果法則と関係ないんだからね
これはいわゆる外の世界の環境とは
環境と関係なく 内だけの原因結果で感情が続くんです
嫌な人がいる時だけ すごく気分が悪くて怒っていて
その人といた途端 また気分が元に戻るならば
もう環境でしょうに それだったら自分が怒りたくなければ
いい環境でいれば十分で
そうじゃないでしょうに
嫌な人が帰っても怒っているんだから
それがどこまでその怒りが膨張するかと
まだわからないし そういうことだから
やっぱりこの感情の感情がある限り
我々は自由じゃないんです
だからこの欲は素晴らしいとか
そんなくだらん話なんかには乗ってはいけないんですよ
それは悟った人が言ってる話ではなくて
そこら辺にいるもう大失敗している連中が言ってる話でしょう
怒りがないと仕事はできないんだとかね
競争できないんだとかね
それでも怒りでもって苦しめば
もう本人が自己破壊するだけで
だからこの感情 貪瞋痴というかね
煩悩っていうのはものすごい危険なもので
そこで我々の自由がなくなって
なくなってしまって もう奴隷になって束縛されて
だからお釈迦様がアッパマーダというたったちょっとしたことを推薦する
気づいてみなさいと 怒りが今怒りだと
これが嫉妬だと 自分の感情に
これが混乱している 今混乱状態にいると気づいた瞬間で
混乱状態から必ずしも行うべき行為をしないことになる
混乱状態でいる人は何かもとんでもないことをやるでしょうに
わけもわからないこと
自分が今混乱状態でいるということをわかった瞬間で
ではちょっと停止しましょうと
ということにオートでそうなるんです
例えば子供にすごく優しくニコニコとアドバイスしましょうと言うと思ったところで
でも自分が怒っている
怒っていたっても すごくニコニコと優しくアドバイスしますよってできるわけないんですよ
いきなり怒鳴りつけるんです
だから今怒ってると思ったら子供にちょっとアドバイスしようという気持ちがなくなっちゃうんです
今やっちゃうとまずいんだから
ということで だからそれで自由になる
決まってることはしてないんです
自分でその瞬間で自分の判断で生きているんです
だからアッパマーダっていうのは
この気づくというたった一言葉
不放逸というよりも それで煩悩が微妙な煩悩も巨大な煩悩も消えてしまうと
また山火事の例に戻りますけど
山っていえば森ですから
いろんな植物がありますね
それで火側はもう片っ端から燃やして回していく
そこでこの煩悩の場合はもうちょっと働きは違いますけど
この 何か巨大で何か微妙な煩悩かというと
それも理解してほしい
森の場合はもう大きな木は大きい木であって
小さな雑草はもう小さな植物であってわかるでしょうね
煩悩といえば そんなにまあ千五百あるというんですけど
まとめれば貪瞋痴という三すですから
怒り 欲と怒りと無知というね
三すでしょうし こちらに何か巨大で何か小さいかと
これで欲もやっぱり千五百ですから
五百種類になるんです
怒りも五百種類になるんです
無知も五百種類になるんです
それで千五百なんです
そこで じゃあ嫉妬ということを見ましょう
で 巨大な嫉妬っていうのはすぐわかりやすい
自分が今嫉妬しているんだと
あの人のことはもう嫌と
それがわかりやすい しかし
例えば二人がすごい仲のいい友達がいる
友達だから目を決して嫉妬の対象にはなりません
でも 微妙に友達にもいろいろ自分よりはいいところがある
そこでちょっとからかってやろうと何とかする
それが自分がちゃんとちょっと友達だからね
からかっただけ もう楽しいんだからということで自分がそう勘違いする
もしかするとあれ嫉妬かもしれません
微妙 わからないんです
で 奥さんが旦那さんにご飯を作る
男っていうのは大体体に悪いものを食べたがりますから
[笑い]だから普通は旦那のことを心配している場合は
もう食べたいものはそう簡単には作ってくれない
もういろいろ無茶苦茶悪口言いながら
もう別な栄養管理をしちゃう
もう辛い味噌汁飲みたかもしれませんだけど
これは塩分がということで控えて味噌汁を作る
飲んでみたら男まずいなこれは
とかね 言ってももう何も文句も言わないんだから
もう我慢して生活はしたりする
まあ普通は大体そういうパターンですけど
それで突然奥さんがやっぱり旦那の気分に合わせてなんとかしなくちゃいけない
もう体に悪くたっても
今日はもういっぱい焼肉作ってやりましょうと大量に作ってあげたりする
それで自分がまあ旦那の気分も聞いてあげたという自分をごまかすんです
もしかすると旦那にしたら怒ってる可能性あります
すごいおいしくごちそう作ったんだから怒ってくれるわけないでしょ
すごく腕を振って 結構お金も使って料理作ったんだだから旦那も今日は奥さんが気分がいいやと思っちゃう
奥さんもやっぱりもうやっぱり旦那もまあまあまあ
その人の気分 気分通りに生活させるのは当たり前ではないかというふうな気持ちなんですけど
その中でもうそんなに食いたければ食っちゃえという怒りが隠れている可能性はあります
それで死んでも私は知りませんよと
そういう風に 人に優しくするんですけど
それってちょっと違うところもあります
だからそれは怒ったら怒りでもはっきりわかります
あの微妙な煩悩っていうのはなかなか分からないんです
同じ怒りなんですけど
同じ嫉妬なんですけど
で それであの いろんな形で機能するんです
あの 何と言いますか 変身して
怒りが優しさに変身する
例えば嫉妬も優しさに変身する
例えば相手のことを嫉妬する
で 嫉妬してたらあんた出て行きなさいという風に喧嘩して別れたのはもうはっきりしています
それは分かりやすい 大きい大きな木です
裏に嫉妬あるんですけど
自分もそれ忘れちゃって
あの人すごくいい人だから
かっこいい人だから仲良くしなくちゃいけないんだと言って
とことん仲良くする 自分とものすごいいい友達になるために必要なことは何でもする
だからもう本人も相手も
この人はすごく優しいんだと
すごい親切だと お互い様はそういうふうにもう決まってるんですが
もしかするとではなくて
裏に嫉妬が隠れていてそうさせるんです
その場合は微妙な嫉妬なんです
微妙と言ったっても小さいわけじゃないんです
あまり演じているんだから
そこはある限りも人は自由じゃないんです
だから全ての煩悩をなくさなくちゃいけないんです
で  それってどうすればいいかっていうことは
やっぱり常に気づくということで
その自由が現れてきます
いつでも自分に気づいている
外から怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬が生まれるんだったら
それも気づいておく 自分の体
あんまりかっこよくないんだから
自分が人のことを嫉妬するんだったら
それは体のこれは体のせいだと
で 気づいてみれば 嫉妬がそこで落ち着いていく
そうやって常に自分の心の状況を見るということはアッパマーダなんで
その人は酔ってる状態じゃないんです
今こんな状態だよと知ってる人は酔ってないんです
その人が自由になるんです
その人は苦しみから脱出するんです
他の人はみんなそのままで
そのまんまだったらありがたいんですけど
どんどんどんどん悪くなる道を選んでいるんです
あるお坊さんがこの瞑想を教えてもらって
森に入って一人で瞑想するんです
すごい真剣 真面目に で
瞑想っていうのは一人でやるものです
みんなでやりましょうと言っちゃうと
これは完全な騙し機能で一人も悟れません
全く一人で自分でやりなさいという
なんで言ってるのかと
グループメディテーションはなんで仏教でないのかと
いうとこの心がものすごく自分を騙して演じるんだからなんです
一人で自分の意思で自分の気持ちでやると
そこら辺から解放されます
ですから このやらせるということはない
だから昔からお坊さんたちに瞑想のやり方を教えてあげて
じゃあやってくださいと言っちゃうと
みんなもうどこかに出ていくんです
指導者がいるところから出ていく
出て行って瞑想する それで
このお坊さんはすごい真剣に瞑想して
なかなか悟り開けない
はぁなかなかうまくいかないんだ
もうもう一度お釈迦様と会って話したいと
だからもう何か自分の心の中で何かおかしいなところはあるんでしょうと
自分ではわからないんだからね
お釈迦様にもう一度会って聞こうかなということで
で 戻るんですよ だから戻るためにも
もう何ヶ月かかかるでしょうに
しかし このお坊さんは瞑想している場所から出たんだから
じゃあ瞑想をやめたぞというふうにいい加減になったわけじゃないんです
すごい真剣なんです 悟らなかったんだから
悟れないんだから 頑張っても頑張っても戻るんであって
瞬間瞬間自分の状況を観察はしているんです
お釈迦様のところに戻る間で
そこでも川とかあってね
そこら辺でじゃあ沐浴でもしようかなとやってると
この山火事があったんです
轟々と炎が上がって もう全部燃やしていくんです
それを見ていたんです
そこで火は火であるならば
小さいものも大きいもの何でも燃やすんだと
だから自分が一発で悟ってやるぞということではなくて
サティという機能を使って
その都度その都度その煩悩を燃やしていけばいいんじゃないんですかと
これが方法ではないかと
それはなんでこれぐらい瞑想してるのに悟らないのかとか
なんか大げさに考えていたんですね
そんな火なんかそんな大げさに考えてるわけじゃないんです
炎がいて 好きなものを燃やして次のものを燃やすだけのことだから
結果として山が全部消えてるだけの話で
燃やすものがなくなったら火も消えてしまう
自分がこんな余計なストレスがあっただけで
その瞬間のその瞬間の怒りであろうか
憎しみであろうか 嫉妬であろうか
落ち込みであろうか その瞬間で瞬間で消せばよかったのにと
だからサティだけ大事に守っておけばいいわけ
火だけ大事に守っておけばよかったのに
火っていうのはサティ
気づくことの例えなんです
私は火だけ守っておけばよかったのに
そこでストレスがなくなっちゃった
精神的にあった圧迫感も
えらいことをやってやるぞ
悟ってやるぞと それ自体も煩悩が隠れてるんですよ
悟るぞと思った途端 高慢なんです
でも悟るぞと一生懸命頑張ってる人は高慢なんかとんでもない
悪いと知ってますよ でも自分が微妙に高慢でやられてるっていうことはわからないんです
あれ ストレスが消えちゃってすぐ悟り開くんです
その場で 帰ってる途中で
だからお釈迦様から指導を受けたんだから
お釈迦様はちゃんと悟るところまでは指導しているんです
2回指導する必要はない
大体お釈迦様から指導を受けたら
次に帰るのはお釈迦様ありがとうございますと言うためなんです
このお坊さんがもう一度アドバイスいただきたいと
うまくいかないんだと書いたところで
途中で見事に間に行くんです
なぜ途中で見事にうまくいったかというと
サティだけはいくらなんでもサティ
いわゆる気づくことからは離れなかったんです
だから山火事を見たところで
そのすごい強さに圧倒されちゃって
その感情を自分の心のその気持ちを自分の心の中に入れてみて
で ひらめいたんですね
ですから その例え合わせてこの偈をできてるんです
アッパマーダにアッパマーダラと
いわゆる気づくことにもうくぎ付けちゃって
もうそれで喜んでやってる人
放逸 もう酔って生活することはとんでもない怖いことであると
この怖いっていうことは
ずーっと長い時間かけてそれ説明してたんですよ
感情はだけは独立ではなくて
勝手に行動して いかに人を危険な目に遭わせるかって
その怖い世界なんです
それをわかってるお坊さん
比丘が 煩悩はもう細かい煩悩も大きな煩悩もなんだかんだで燃やしてしまいますよと
だから火が森を燃やすような感じで
その都度その都度のものを
燃やすんですよ まず草を燃やしてやるぞと
それから大きな木にするぞ
そういう計画っていうのは
修行する人がやろうとするんですけど
とんでもない話なんです
そんな放っておけばいいんです
サティという火が自分に当たったものを燃やすんです
次に当たったものを次に燃やすんです
それはもう草であろうか
ちょっとした藪であろうか
大きな木であろうかっていうのは
それは関係ないんです
まあ一応その偈の意味はそれぐらいのことで
で 次の偈もほとんど似ていますから
今日で終了することはできると思います
全く言葉似ています アッパマーダラトビクパマーデーバヤダッシワ
アッパマーダに好んで修行実践する比丘がパマーデーバヤダッシとは怠ることは危険なものだとよく知っている
アバッボーパリハーナそれだけなんですね
新しい言葉は アバッボーというのは不可能である
パリハーナヤというのは堕落すること
気づくことさえあれば堕落ことは不可能です
堕落はしない 次の言葉ニッバーナッセーワサンティティ
ニッバーナというのは涅槃
解脱 彼が解脱のそこそこ側にいるんだよと
だからサティ 気づくことさえあれば
涅槃はすぐそばにあるんです
涅槃のそばに近所にいるんであって
もう堕落することはないんです
サティがある場合は いつでも涅槃に引っかかっているんですよ
自分が この手すりみたいにそれ捕まってるんです
だから電車ででも手すりを捕まってる人はもう倒れるってことはありえないでしょうね
だから何も掴まないで
ただ立って新聞か何か読んでいると
急ブレーキかけちゃうともう倒れてしまうし
怪我もするし だからこの今ずっと説明してたこのサティということ
あるいは気づくということがあれば
もう涅槃に自分がもうまだまだまだ涅槃得てないかもしれませんだけど
一応手すりぐらいのでも捕まってはいるんです
離せません だから堕落するっていうことはありえないんだよと
だからこの気づく実践する人には堕落はなし
ありえない 気づくことはもう忘れた瞬間でもう危ないんです
その瞬間で自由が完璧になくなりますから
束縛された状態になるんだから
酔った動体になるんだから
何するか分からない だから怒っているとか
今怒っている 嫉妬する
今ちょっと嫉妬があるみたいとかね
それをわかる人がやっぱり堕落することはない
悪いことはしないしね
すごい応答的に自動的に悪いことをしない人間にはなります
だから良い人間になろうと思ったら絶対なりませんよ
心清らかにしてやるぞと
全然絶対できません それ自体はもうあまりにも魂機能で
本当回答聞きたいと聞きたいところなんです
私たまに聞くんですけど
ただ怒られてもう二度と来ないんです
こちらには もうこっちは知ってますからね
それは嘘やと 心清らかにしたいとかね
もうわかる 全く見えとんですよ
感情が 高慢やら憎しみやらいろいろあって
それを正当化するためにね
まあそうはなりません
だからそういう大胆なことではなくて
瞬間瞬間の気づき機能をやってみる
だからその場でその場で自分の心をぶつけた煩悩が燃えるだけのことだから
これで十分です そういうことだから
堕落することはありえませんという偈で
そこで一応不放逸の章は終わります
で こちらにもストーリーはあるんですけど
なんかこのストーリーと偈はなかなか合わないんです
まあ一応もうこの偈のストーリーも言いますけどね
ある 村人が出家するんです
でも小さな村でしょうね
そこから来て その村は西城というかね
サーワティという大きな町のそばなんです
で 町の人ではないんです
お釈迦様は町に住んでいたんでしょうし
サーワティはもうコーサラ王様もいたし
アナータピンディカコチがいて
ものすごい大金持ちが仏教を支えていたんです
で この人は田舎から来て
出家して ちゃんと勉強して
また すごい質素な生活をしているんですね
托鉢に出る場合は自分の村に行くんです
で 町と村っていうのは経済的には随分断然違うんです
村でもう何もない 町だったらもう大富豪たちがもうほとんど仏教徒になっていて
もう競ってお布施しているんです
だからサーワティの祇園精舎なんかにいるならば
もうお坊さんたちには欠けているものは何もないんです
アナータピンディカコチなんか来て全部調べるんです
いろいろ一人一人いるところに行って
熱が出ているお坊さんがいる
熱でしょうと言って それでも薬やらなんとかあげたりするし
あるいはお医者さんを呼んであげたりするし
何か栄養失調で 栄養失調だから
あのお坊さんにこういうこういうものとものを言ってあげたりするし
だからもうすごい気楽に
もう何の問題もなく生活できる
しかし このお坊さんはもう西城の方に托鉢には行かない
いつでも自分の生まれてきたあの村に行って托鉢する
そこでまあまあまあ村人も毎日知っている人だから
自分の田舎の人でしょうし
だからあえてわざわざごちそうを作ってあげましょうとかね
そういう気持ちはないでしょうね
毎日のように来る人には何かあるものをあげるだけで
それをもらって召し上がって
そのまま森の中に入る
それで他のもう悟ってないお坊さんたちは
なんであの人のあの態度はと
お釈迦様のところでいっぱいお坊さんたちがいて
もういろんな聖者さんの法事なんかにも行ったりして
みんな仲良くしているのに
こんな大大スケールでアナータピンディカコチやらコーサラ国王やらお布施をしているのに
一つにも参加しない いつでも自分の親戚のところに
親戚がいるところに行くんだと
出家したんですけど なかなか執着は捨ててないな
この野郎とかと悪口言ってるんです
それはお釈迦様の耳にも入ります
かなりお坊さんの悪口を言われてたみたいんです
で 性格は悪いなと分かったら
お釈迦様はちゃんとそういう人々は呼びます
呼んで審判するんです
出家世界はすごい厳しいんですよ
もう出家して自由じゃないんです
まるっきり逆なんです
一人で生活したっても
もう全体的な決まりは一つ残らず守らなくちゃいけないんです
だからそれも覚えておいた方がいいんです
日本でもなんか出家したら自由じゃないかなとかね
これは勘違いで甘くはないんです
在家生活よりもかなり厳しい
でお釈迦様はそのお坊さん呼んで
もうあなたに対してこういう訴えがあるんだと
あんたはすごくこのもう執着して親戚に離れない状態でいるんだと
他のお坊さんたちの行事なんかにも参加しないで
すぐ親戚のところに行くんだぞと
というのは本当でしょうか？と
聞いたら そのお坊さんが私はこの親戚と全然感情的な関係は何もないんだと
私はただ一日自分に体に必要なものだけ
必要のところからただ生きていればいい
豪華なお布施なんかには行かなくてもいいと
だから そこら辺の貧しいところに行って
ふっとちょっと命繋げるだけのことしかもらってないんだよと
ずっと今まで一回も だからあの訴えは
まあ何て言いますか 根拠はないんだと
親戚のところに行って
あれ作ってくれ これ作ってくれとかね
そういうこと全くなくて
ただ命繋げるために必要なものだけもらって
それ食べてから私はじゃあみんないるところに行って仲良くしようと
その気持ちもないんだと
出家者のところに行って
私はそのまま森に入るんだと
森に入って 私は自分の修行をするんだと
だから極端な 何て言いますか
質素な生活 極端にできるだけの
それ以上はできない 減らすことは
それはこの最低限のレベルで私は生きてますよと
それでそのお坊さんはみんなの行事なんかに参加しなかったのは
親戚のことを可愛くてたまらんかったではなくて
こんな贅沢 大げさなことはいらんと
ただ死ななきゃ十分でしょうと
人間として それから修行すればいいんじゃないかということで
あの村にいつでも必ず行くんだと
それでお釈迦様は この人には訴えは全く根拠がないということもありましたから
まあ番太無罪だということではなくて
まあ君の生き方はね まあこのようなもう質素な生き方をしっかりと教えてる教えに君が入ったんだから
まあ珍しくはないんだと
昔もそういう風に この動物の世界ででも質素で生きるということは実践した人々はいましたよと言って
あの昔の物語を言うんです
これは動物の物語で あるこのオウムがヒマラヤ山脈の方で
あの大きいイチジクかな
みたいな まあイチジク種類ですから
これでは分かりませんですけど
イチジクかの植物たくさんありますからね
で まあイチジクで今しましょう
イチジクの木があって
そちらに住んでいるんです
そこで イチジクっていうのは一年中実るわけじゃないんです
そこで実ってる時はそれを美味しく食べて
その木で生活していて
実がなくなっちゃうと
もういろいろ葉っぱとかありますから
葉っぱ食べるんだと 別な木なんかに行かない
あの木は美味しい あの木も美味しい
あの木は美味しいとかね
そこで冬になってくると
もう葉っぱも何もないんですね
そうすると あの その同じ木の皮とかなんとか取って
食べてその木に住んでいる
別なところには行かない
それで前にガンジス川ありますから
ガンジス川に行って そこから水を飲んで
また同じ木に戻ると それで帝釈天は鳥っていうのはあっち行ってこっち行って
もう餌探して回るのに
この鳥はおかしいと 餌がなくても全然落ち着いて同じ木に住んでいるんだと
それで帝釈天は何したんですかというと
じゃあこれを試さなくちゃいけないんだと
自分の神っていうのはいろいろ力あるんだから
あの木を全部枯れてしまさせたんです
で 全部枯れてしまって
あっちこっちもう割れてしまって
もうもう木がもう完璧に枯れてしまったんです
そこで風が吹いたり いろんなことすると
さらに木が落ちたり もう割れたり
穴開けたりする でもその鳥はそれでもその木から出ていかないんです
食べ物ないでしょうに
枯れたところで粉とかありますからね
粉とか食べているんです
同じ木の そこでものすごく暑い昼は
でも落ち着いているということで
でもその鳥 帝釈天も結局は負けちゃったんです
もうもうそれでも逃げない
もう完璧に木が死んじゃって
もうもうもう枯れた木になっちゃって
もうもう粉になってる
もうもう皮とかね それでもくちばしでちょっとちょっと粉になってるところでも取って取って食べたりしているんですから
それで帝釈天はこの鳥に変身するんです
鳥に変身して 結構立派な木があって
そちらに来て このオウムと喋るんです
この森は大きくて それほど美しい樹木がいっぱいあるんだと
いろんなところでいろんな木の実があるんだと
だから野生の鳥にしたらもう食べ物あふれているんだと
なのに木の粉食べてるあなたはなんでそんなにも落ち着いているのかと
どこにも行かないで これ長いジャータカ物語みたいんですけどね
そこでこのオウムがね
これこちらで省略しています
長すぎて 私もこれはちょっと覚えていないんですけど
で この切りの切りがない欲ある鳥たちはね
あの木にこの木にと飛んで行って
あの果物を食べて この果物でも満足しないでしょうにと
あの木はもっと美味しいんじゃないかと思うんだよと
こちらで何か木の実を食べ
もしかするとあちらの方が美味しいんじゃないかなと
そちらに行って食うんだよと
結局は食うのは食うんだけど
満足はしていないんだと
明日どんな木にとどこら辺に飛びましょうかという気持ちでいるんだよと
それでやがていろんなもうもう狩人たちに捕まえたり
あるいは他の動物にやられたり
命までなくなるんだよと
どうせ命も危険だから
いろんなところに行くと戦わなくちゃいけないし
縄張りもあるでしょうし
でも私はこれで満足しているんだと
たとえこの木がもう実ってあっても
今のような状態で全く何もなくて枯れちゃって
粉しか食べられるものなくても
私は満足するんだと それで命はどうせなくなるものだからね
食べ物も何もなくなっちゃって
死ぬことになっても 私は満足して死ぬんだよと
だから このいわゆる質素で生きることはね
小欲知足っていうことが
私は実践して喜んでいるんだとという話なんで
それで大将はやっぱりなかなか大物だと
バカじゃないんだと この鳥は
ということで 木を元に戻してあげたんです
常に木の実がある いつでも食べ物がある木にしてくれたんだと
で それが昔ので お釈迦様が言ったのは
昔は動物でさえもそういう風にこの小欲知足で大変幸福を味わっていたんだと
今はブッダの世界で 君も小欲知足で大変素晴らしい生き方をしているんだから
素晴らしい結果を得られるでしょうと
だから決して君は悟りから離れているわけじゃないんだと
涅槃のすぐそばにいるんだよと
そのうち悟るでしょうというふうに説法するんです
という話なんですけど
まあ私のいい加減な文学的な評価的な見で言うと
あまりこの偈には合わないような気がしますけど
小欲知足の話もないし
ただサティの話なんですけどね
一応注釈書にあるのはそういうエピソードなんです
それでサティがある比丘は決して堕落しないんだと
で 今日の話はそこら辺で終了いたします
一つよろしいですか はい
鳥籠に閉じ込められた鳥の話なんですけども
いつでも扉さえ開けられればですね
逃げようと思っている鳥と
そこで安心して生活している鳥と比べた場合に
逃げようとしている鳥の方が賢いといいますか
いいというお話だったんですけども
最初私はその環境の中で不平不満言わずに生活している鳥の方がストレスもなくて賢いのかなと思ったんですけど
条件が変わってその扉が開いたら
その時にまた判断して行動すればいいのかなと思ったんですけども
だからまあ例えあまりは良くないかもしれませんだけど
それで酔っていてね その環境に
我輩は幸せやと 餌はくれるは水はくれるんだと思っちゃうと
もう逃げないでしょ だから人間というのは我輩は幸福だという生き方をしているんだから
解脱しよう サティ実践しようということは全くもう考えていないということなんです
逆に文句を言うんです
なんでこんなややこしいことをしなくちゃいけないかと
それでそれ それなくたって楽しいんじゃないかと言っても
もう無知だけでしょ 本当に人生は楽しいのかと
どれほど危険なことをやっているのかわかっているのかと
だからそれよりは豚とか鶏に例えた方がもっと良かったかもしれません
豚にはちゃんと餌をくれるんですけどね
豚が我ほど幸せなものがないんだぞと思ったって食べられるでしょうに
で だからこの束縛されている命っていうのは何の価値もないんだっていう話なんですね
視点がちょっと違ってましたんですけどね
あとそれからですね 日本も裁判に一般の国民が参加するような法律ができるということなんですけども
で その時にその まあ仏教を信じてる人がその信条とかで辞退することもできるような方策が取られるという話もあるんですけども
そういう時にその まあ一応裁判員に任命された時には進んで行って
一緒にそういう まあ一般的には死刑とかですね
無期懲役に関するような裁判に関わるらしいんですけども
そういうにも一緒に まあそういう汚い世界といいますか
汚いのかどうかはわかりませんけども
そういうところで一緒にそういうことを論じたりするっていうのはどうなのかなと最近ちょっと考えてたんですけども
アドバイスがいただければと思います
アドバイスしたって意味がないんですけど
自分の意見だけは言いますけど
人の感情に適した判断出そうと思っちゃうと
それが裁判じも何でもないんです
公平な審判でも何でもないんです
もし一般人も裁判員として行くならば
それはそれで構いませんけど
基本的にはみんなの感情に相応する適用する判断欲しいというならば正しい判断じゃないんです
感情にはキリがないんだから
ないし それと被害者と加害者っていうのは関係ないんですからね
一人一人別々な人間でしょうに
だから一般人も入って紛れもなくこの人は犯罪者だと
人を殺してるんだと 一般人の目から見ても
もう何の疑いもなく その罪を犯してるんだと
という判決を出すためだったら
人間がいろいろ判断ミスを犯すし
それは妨げるために一般人が参加するならば
それは別に問題はありません
どうせ判決は法律家出すんだから
自分で死刑だと決めるわけないでしょ
一般人は  一応多数決が取られると
だからそれは有罪か無罪かというね
で やっぱり死刑の場合は多数決も良くないと思いますよ
死刑はもう千人一致でないと
もしかすると人を殺したかもしれませんということはね
冗談でしょう もう無罪の人はアメリカでも結構やっちゃいますからね
罪を犯してないのに捕まって殺したりするとかね
まあ公平な というのはあり得ない世界に生きてますからね
何をしたってもそういう人間やってるものだからね
あんまりどちらでも同じことやと思いますけど
あれはまあ社会的なことで人を殺したならば
まあ死刑にするっていうことは
まあもういくつかの国々しか死刑制度ないんですけど
で 日本みたいな文化的な社会はね
なんでそんな死刑制度をいまだに持ってるかっていうね
問題もありますけど 自分の国でもまあ昔 1950年7年か 8年かのそこら辺でも死刑はやめてありましたし
またいろいろ問題起きたりして
また死刑を元に戻したりとか
また取り消したりとかね
あれも政治家の感情で死刑やめるならばやめたということにすればいいしね
人間っていうのはあまりにも残酷な殺人なんか出てくると
もうもう腹が立って やっぱりもう一度もう復活するぞということにするんですよ
それも正しくはないんです
あの新聞なんか読むと
あの なんかある女の人なんですけど
随分見事に淡々とこの
このスリランカのこのピーネル法っていうのはもう甘すぎやと
ピーネル法っていうのは何でしたっけ？この
罰の体罰 体罰じゃないね
再罰システムがね で そんなのでそういう残酷な犯罪
あっちこっちで起こるんではないかと
だからもう厳しくすぐすぐ判断して
みんな死刑にするべきですよと
それなんで女なのにこんなことを書くのか
やっぱり本人がイスラム教なんですね
それはイスラムのまあ理論かもしれませんだけど
すぐすぐ死刑にするならば
犯罪は減るんだよっていうのはね
どうかな わからないんですね
だからマレーシア シンガポールでも一応麻薬使うと死刑にしていますし
で そこで隣隣の国も同じことにしなくちゃいけない
だからスリランカもおそらく麻薬所持した人
すごい罰とか死刑とか決めてるみたいに誰も死刑にしてないんですけど
それでも まあそっち方面もありますけど
まあこれはまあ社会のことでね
仏教にはそんなに関係ないんで
仏教の場合は人を殺したら
その人はもう誰が審判下さなくても
まあ自分ではもう思い存分報いを受けますから
強烈な罰は自動的に受けますよ
例えば自分の子供が殺されたという場合は
親にとっては納得もいかない
なんであんな可愛い子はこうなったんでしょうかと
長い間自分が死ぬまで悲しまなくちゃいけない
例えば相手のことを憎しまなくても
我が子が亡くなった気持ちっていうのはね
強烈に痛いでしょうね
で 納得もいかない だからひどいんです
何か原因があるんだったら納得いくんですよ
例えば家の中でも もうどうしてももう手に負えない
ものすごい暴力を振るう
そこでもう外に行ったっても
もうもうなかなかもう手に負えない
で 誰かにやられちゃったと言うと
もう泣きながら あの子は本当にそういう性格でしたからと納得いくでしょ
それもできないんですよ
だからさらに苦しいんです
だからそれは過去自分がやったことの結果なんです
人々に悲しみを与えたんです
だったら味わいなさいと
十分 それだから寿命のない
またはもうそんなに恵まれてない誰かが自分に子供として生まれてくるんです
そこで愛情いっぱい育てたとしても
その子供にはその長い寿命がないんです
その人も誰かに殺される業があるんです
で うまく組み合わせているんですよ
だからまあ罪からはもう逃げませんだから
わざわざ私たちは人に罰を与えるっていうことは本当はいらん
そうしますと 心情から辞退しても
それはその人の判断で辞退するならばするでいいし
ん？ 裁判員に任命された場合ですね
そういう因果の法則で
罰を受ける人は罰を受けるしということで
わざわざ人間が新たに罰を与える必要はないから
そういう考えのもとで私は辞退しましたが
どういうふうに直接言うのかどうか分からないですけど
そういう意味合いで辞退するのは
その人はその人で その人の判断でやるならそれでもそれでいいという
辞退するのは辞退する人の気持ちだからね
辞退するのはよろしいし
辞退したくない場合でも
ただ客観的にこの人がもう人を殺した
何何人を殺したことは百パーセント証明できるかと
それはただちょっとした研究をして調べるぐらいのことだから
それは言うぐらいのことはね
別にその人が悪人であろうが可愛い人であろうが
それは自分には関係ないんだと
ただ罪を犯したかないか
ただそれだけの話でしょう
事実を確認してそれから判断する
その場合に法律で判断するんだから
私はその人は死刑にした方がいいと思いますよと言ったっても意味がないでしょうし
いえ 私は死刑にしたって
この人は手足先に切断して殺した方がいい
そうでなきゃもうもうもう気が済まないんだよって
そんなことできるんでしょ
でも人間っていうのは感情が入り込みますから
結構危険なものなんです
日本のシステムの場合はもう一生懸命反省して逃げますからね
もうアホなシステムなんですね
だから ずる賢い人にはものすごく名演技で反省すれば
もう感情の世界では理屈は通ってないんだからね
逃げます 残酷な惨殺を起こして一生懸命反省するとかね
まあそれ反省するのは勝手でいいんですけど
あなたはやったことはやったんだからという話ですけど
本当は 本当は人の命を奪いましたと
まあ私の問題はだからといってあえて死刑にする必要はあるのかというね
まあどちらにしたっても
まあもう矛盾は終わらない
例えば終身刑にするということは
その人が死ぬまで守ってあげるということになるんです
税金で ちゃんとご飯食べさせて運動させて
無料で死ぬまで面倒見るということになるんです
そうしたっても損するだけで
死刑にしたんだからと言ったり
どうせ人は死ぬんだから
別にその人にとってはそんな
何もないんですよ 殺される人にとっては
そういう答えではあります
イスラムの国々みたいに公で
アフガニスタンであったでしょうね
女の人なんかもこのままみんなの前で
アフガニスタンでもサッカーなんか昔は結構強かったし
サッカー場は処刑場なんです
みんな集めてもらって
みんなの前で殺すと 殺すぐらいの罪じゃないんですよ
もう誰かと喋っていたとかね
それぐらいのことなんですけど
それで男は首を吊ってそのまま置いておく
あれって何やってるんでしょうかと
それは世の中から犯罪をなくすつもりですかね
余計に見る見る人にとっても
怒り憎しみを作るだけでしょうに
だからもうそういう犯罪の答えがないんです
答えはとことん自業自得で
もう絶対逃げられないんだよというブッダの真理しかないんです
どこへ逃げるつもりかと
逃げるところないんだろ
自分の内からですよと
内からやられますよというとかなり怖いんです
もう全くもやりたくないんです
その場合は 自分の母親はそういう風に教えられたんだから
もう隠れてでも動物でもイジリを殺そうという気持ちには全然なりません
すっごく怖く感じるんです
私は仏教の閻魔さんの話もおかしいと思いますからね
何で閻魔さんがいるのかと
それはインドであった一般的なエピソード物語だと思いますけどね
論理的に考えるとバカバカらしいんですね
閻魔さんも地獄にいないとね
もう判断 審判できませんだからね
悪人たちがもう一旦天国に行くならばね
だから閻魔さんは誰よりも罪を犯していないといけないでしょ
ずっと地獄にいるんだから
そうすると 誰よりも罪を犯した人には他の罪を犯した人を判断任せるわけじゃないでしょうに
成り立たないんです まあまあ今日まあそんな長々と喋る必要はないんですけど
はい ではちょっと時間を過ぎてしまいましたが
ダンマパダの部分はこれくらいにしたいと思います
この後ちょっとしてますので
五時半頃からまた勉強会の方を開始したいと思いますので
また本堂の方にお集まりください
では 最後 三拝で終わりたいと思います
三拝